anthony daniels nine saga film champion
how are you doing
it's getting to be evening here but your
energy is
great and you are gonna really enjoy
the star wars lego holiday special less
talky talky more fighty fighting
oh so cute you've now been a part of
both the uh star wars holiday specials
which
it was something that i feel like for so
many years was so taboo to even bring up
like
when i interviewed the actors i was like
i don't think i'm allowed to mention the
holiday special but now
i feel like it's it's we're clear so how
do you feel about it today looking back
at that experience
well when they came to me and said we're
gonna make a holiday special i kind of
winced and said are you crazy
because people remember people people
you know
uh get angry about it and and so on and
they said no no
it's gonna be different and it is
different
it's lego so with lego you can
break all the rules that were ever made
in entertainment you have these funny
little block figures that kind of
wobble around the set in an
intrinsically cute way
you can you cannot take you cannot but
laugh at a lego figure because they
basically funny and then the
scriptwriters
added a great bunch of humor there and
they put an adventure in which you
couldn't do in a movie and not in a star
wars movie
but you can do it in a star wars lego
thing
and they've done that so you uh as an
adult will find all sorts of
references and as a young child you're
just going to
revel in the funness of it all
then some um you know some adults can
have to explain to
various younger children no this is this
and this is this and that's what
happened there
and then they're gonna grow up and watch
the moves again it's you know it goes on
star wars
continues down the generations of them
for generations yeah
happy life day
she says it may be a happy life day for
you but personally she's seen happier
ones
so have you revisited the the 1978
holiday special have you
reread the script or re-watched the
movie i have
the original script um and it i think is
a picture of it in my book
it's in my attic here in london i have
the original script
and i tried to read it it's not easy but
you can actually watch it on youtube
and that's not easy either but um so
i did revisit it in my book because i i
remember
it was a seminal moment because it was
so peculiar to be in
and then to see it because it on the set
it was so mournful
i can't tell you it was meant to be a
really happy life day in that sequence
it was dreadful it was like a funeral
with all these workers
in the dark it was really sinister well
there's
nothing like this here but i am the only
person
in this galaxy to have worked on both
holiday specials
how about that that's true i mean i
because i mean you when you did star
wars you have to be like oh this is
pretty weird but when you're on the set
of the holiday special
was there a moment like where you're
like oh man
this is this is real strange yeah um
you you can't see my face okay because
i'm inside c3p
but you can look i mean really go to the
far end of it the end of it on youtube
and if you look at harrison
ford's face you look at carrie's face
and you look at mark hamill's face
you are reading what have we got into
here
i'm smiling but inside i'm feeling very
very strange
and literally if you look at it mark is
smiling like an idiot because he just
harrison is braving it out you know he's
a pro well last time we spoke to you
told me that the rise of skywalker was
likely going to be your last time
playing 3po
but it now now we're at the holiday
special we have another 3po
do you think this could be the final
thing do you think you could we could
see 3po again
uh there's gonna be some other stuff out
soon but disney would prefer me not to
mention it and this
tape will now self-destruct in five
seconds
well john
maybe not major movies but i'm so
grateful and lucky
that i have all these these outlets
holiday special
various cartoon stuff uh other outlets
as well
how lucky am i that 3po has
looked after me for so long now but it's
not over he's going to look after me in
the future
and of course i look after him let's not
forget
well unfortunately i'm out of time but
you're always so delightful to talk to
oh thank you i hope one day we will meet
again at a press conference
somewhere near you live and in person
until then may the force be with you may
the force be with you
you want to shoot first after you
you